IT'S FRIDAY.
THAT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR -- HOW
TONE DEAF IT IS.
AND THE CLASSIC KID SHOW GETS
SERIOUS.
BUT FIRST, SHAMELESS PANDERING
BY THE LEFT TO THE SOCIAL
JUSTICE WARRIORS.
JOINING US WITH ALL OF THE
DETAILS, HE'S BACK.
RAYMOND ARROYO.
OKAY, RAYMOND.
TWO-FER TONIGHT, DOUBLE-TROUBLE
WITH YOU TONIGHT.
NEVER STOPS.
WHAT ARE THE 2020 CANDIDATES
DOING NOW?
>> IT'S ALMOST EMBARRASSING AT
THIS POINT.
CNN AS YOU REFERENCED EARLIER
DID ANOTHER 2020 TOWN HALL
MARATHON WHICH, AND THIS COULD
TELL US HOW 2020 MIGHT GO, IT
TANKED THEIR RATINGS.
THE EQUALITY TOWN HALL GAVE THE
DEMOCRAT CANDIDATES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CURRY FAVOR WITH
THEIR RELIABLE LGBT CONSISTENCY.
LET'S START WITH BOOKER WHO WAS
THROWING HIMSELF AT ONE OF THE
QUESTIONERS.
>> HANDSOME HAIR CUTS.
>> GOING TO SAY THE SAME THING?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU HAVE A BEAUTIFUL MAN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
MANY PEOPLE HAVE NO IDEA THAT --
>> MAKE OUR PRESIDENT BALD
AGAIN.
>> I'M HERE FOR IT.
>> HOW ADORABLE?
ARE WE SEEING MABA HATS -- MAKE
AMERICA BALD AGAIN?
IS THAT HOW WE'RE GOING TO WIN
MICHIGAN, RAYMOND?
>> THEY'LL ONLY HAVE VISORS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO RUIN THE
NATURAL HUMAN HEAD.
JOE BIDE SEASON IN THE CENTER OF
THIS.
HE'S BEEN KNOWN TO EMBELLISH
STORIES A BIT, LAURA.
I WONDER HOW MUCH THIS IS TRUE.
THIS IS HE AND HIS FATHER
ENCOUNTERING A GAY COUPLE,
WATCH.
>> TWO WELL-DRESSED MEN KISSED
ONE ANOTHER AS I WAS OPENING THE
DOOR.
I HAD NOT SEEN THAT.
HE SAID IT'S SIMPLE, HONEY, THEY
LOVE EACH OTHER.
I CAME OUT -- I DIDN'T COME OUT.
WHEN I PUBLICLY STATED --
>> WELL, THAT WOULD BE NEWS.
>> I GOT SOMETHING TO TELL YOU.
>> TRIED TO FIGURE IT OUT A
WHILE AGO.
>> WOULD SAY, LAURA?
>> I WAS JUST SAD FOR HIM.
>> IT WAS.
IT'S A DESPERATE ATTEMPT TO
PANDER.
ASIDE FROM THEIR PEOPLE, ALL OF
THESE CANDIDATES ARE AT A LOSS.
THEY'RE NOT GAY OR LESBIAN.
IT'S A -- 82% OF LGBT PEOPLE
VOTE DEMOCRAT.
KAMELA HARRIS.
>> MY PRONOUNS ARE SHE, HER, AND
HERS.
>> SHE, HER, AND HERS.
MINE TOO.
>> IS THIS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO DO WHEN WE GO IN THE
ROOM.
THAT'S THE NEW HELLO, YOU LOOK
GREAT, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
AND WHAT'S YOUR PERSONAL
PRONOUN.
>> HE APOLOGIZED.
CUOMO SAID PLEASE READ, WHEN
SENATOR HARRIS SAID HER PRONOUNS
WERE SHE, HER, AND HERS, I SAID
MINE TOO, I SHOULD NOT HAVE.
>> HE HAD TO APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
IT WASN'T FUNNY.
BUT THE ATTEMPT, AS PATHETIC AS
IT WAS.
>> IT WAS ALL -- IT WAS A PANDER
FEST FOR HOURS AND HOURS.
DIDN'T HELP THE RATINGS.
JOY BEHAR WAS SERENADED BY
PEOPLE DURING HER BIRTHDAY ON
"THE VIEW," WATCH.
♪ JOY COME TO THE WORLD
THE TIME HAS COME
IN CHOIR
IN DIKE
IN PEACE ♪
>> OKAY --
>> LAURA?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I MEAN HOW FLAT
CAN ONE SING, FIRST OF ALL?
I'M FOCUSING ON HOW FLAT THE
TONE IS.
>> MUST WE MAKE A CHRISTMAS
CAROL THIS PROFANE BY TILTING A
BIRTHDAY TOWARDS IMPEACHMENT.
IDEOLOGY TALL WAY HERE, IT'S
SAD.
>> WELL, I HOPE WE CAN HAVE A
CHRISTMAS SEASON WITHOUT
BRINGING IMPEACHMENT REMOVAL, I
MEAN IN A PARTRIDGE IN A PEAR